[Music]
I'm the one
we got a special podcast here for you
today with an evolutionary biology
professor of evolutionary biologies we
can even say former professor of
evolutionary biology uh it's got a
podcast called Dark Horse podcast
uh Joe and I were talking because of a
clip you guys did on the podcast
together and I put it on uh Twitter and
it got a lot of uh feedback and I said
man I love that clip between the two of
you guys he said you should have them on
I said send me his number and then Rob's
like he's scheduled to come on I said
you got to be kidding me how weird is
this right but it's great to have you on
a podcast thanks for having me I'm glad
to be here yes you're you're making a
lot of friends the last two years it's
you you're you're making a lot of new
allies you're pissing off some would say
the institution some of the people that
are telling people what to do without
wanting to hear the other side of the
argument but you are definitely making a
lot of friends I am losing friends and
making more and better friends are there
any friends you've lost without naming
them that you're surprised you would
have ever lost that friend well I I've
now learned this lesson a couple of
times every time one confronts one of
these really difficult puzzles in which
there's a lot at stake you lose people
that surprise you and then people emerge
in your life that you didn't expect and
so you know in the Evergreen situation I
don't know how familiar your audience
will be with that but I think it's good
to know about it I know about it I think
it'd be good if you share with all right
I'll give them the very brief version if
they want a a better exploration they
can look at Mike Nana's three-part
documentary on it it really covers it
very well or Benjamin Boyce's Channel
also does but my wife and I were
professors at Evergreen for 15 years and
Heather was literally the college's most
popular Professor I wasn't terribly far
behind we had a really dedicated group
of students who went back and forth
between our our programs and because of
the way Evergreen worked
we knew our students extremely well we
could go into the field with them for
weeks at a time was a great place
and on May 23 2017 50 students that I
had never met before streamed into the
building where I was teaching chanting
my name demanding that I'd be fired or
resigned
and their accusation was that I was a
racist
an idea that they had actually picked up
from some faculty members who didn't
like me very much because I stood in the
way of their attempt to change the
college which would have been a threat
to the college if it had happened and
and I said so
in faculty meetings and then when that
became impossible I said so over email
in any case that protest became
uh violent it descended into violence
over the course of a couple days and the
protesters
made the mistake of filming everything
they did and then uploading it I think
they uploaded it to Facebook but it was
later put on YouTube by somebody who
wanted the world to see it and when the
world did see these students confronting
me something was clearly off so the
incident did not work out the way they
had hoped that it would
um and that uh catapulted me into the
public eye we
requested demanded and then uh initiated
the process of suing the college because
they had obviously created an unsafe
working environment
students the president of the college
who in some ways had triggered this
whole episode
ordered the police who were
subordinate to him to stay out of the
conflict between students and us and the
students created a a patrol they
wandered the campus with baseball bats
they actually battered another student
they were looking for me stopping
traffic searching cars this sort of
thing to put things in perspective this
is 2017. right yeah were these students
within the school or they just came out
of the Woodworks to show up at the
school these were very definitely
students at the school and uh so you
know this was of course
Downstream of a A diversity equity and
inclusion movement that had become quite
powerful the school was a very liberal
place and so it's not surprising that we
would have seen such a movement
uh and the problem is that the the
policy changes at the college that that
movement wanted to initiate would have
destroyed the place they were going to
be lethal to its functioning and it was
my obligation as a faculty member to
point that out to be fair but
politically are you a uh uh a pro-trump
supporter Mega guy because if they're
doing that to you you must be a big
supporter of trump well they might think
so yeah I describe myself as a reluctant
radical and the reason I say reluctant
radical is that I believe after many
years of studying the question that our
civilization can't really continue this
way that what we've done has been
brilliant there's of course been lots of
Carnage but our system is not
sustainable in the way it currently
exists and so it has to be retooled for
Humanity to continue to prosper but
so that's the part that makes me a
radical is that I believe only radical
change can save us but I also know that
if you take a system that functions and
our system does function and you alter
it you are very likely to do harm and
you are very likely in your solution
making to bring about unintended
consequences which can be disastrous so
I am a a progressive but I am one with
trepidations about change and and uh
anyway no I'm not uh not a trump
supporter
um I I'm also not a Biden supporter
wasn't a Clinton supporter I believe we
need to find a new Direction were you
like a Bernie Sanders supporter at some
point I was I am no longer
um I I think that Bernie did represent a
uh a actual challenge to the power
structure that has us locked into this
bad trajectory
um but I think he's he's lost his way
that said even when I was a supporter of
his I wasn't overly convinced that he
understood what direction we needed to
go but he did represent the possibility
of breaking out of the the death spiral
that I see our duopoly is having uh
speaking of uh speaking of duopoly would
you say over the last five years since
2017 you've had to do more mental
wrestling with who you identify with
more than ever in your life politically
speaking no because
2017 is not where these questions uh
arrived on my desk at first I've been
thinking about the question of how
civilization functions as an
evolutionary biologist uh I was a member
of the game B movement which was a small
group of people who were interested in
complex systems and interested in
figuring out what the next phase of
civilization should look like so I had
done a lot of thinking about it and
frankly I think people make a mistake
they they tend to affiliate
with people and adopt their ideology and
my sense is that ideology is a problem
especially if you pick it up because of
the people who hold it
so my sense is even if there was nobody
else on Earth who agreed with me
that we have to change the way
civilization functions
right I would still be a progressive by
the technical definition because I still
believe we have to alter things if we're
to do well and and my job is to convince
people that that's true if I'm right or
if I'm not right I have to allow them to
convince me that I've got it wrong and I
will change my position I I so you said
something uh you said uh uh that we do
need to make some radical changes but if
we do make it too radical we may have
some you know side effects or
repercussions for making the changes as
well so when we had Neil deGrasse Tyson
here I asked him about how he would
change the educational system there's a
few topics I want to go through with you
Chad gbt just uh an article came out
saying it just passed a bar exam I want
to get your feedback on that one right
there a poll that I did on Twitter which
you and I talked about the poll hey
which one of these is going to be the
biggest uh negative consequence in U.S
you know that we're experiencing right
now we'll talk about that and then of
course we'll talk vaccine and a few
other things but uh isolate getting this
specific concern here Neil deGrasse
Tyson I said how would you change the
educational system to improve it I know
on the election side you came up with a
program uh Unity something you called
unity in 2020 where the president would
have a person from each side to make
sure almost like a vice president model
that you have from both sides that you
can get some counsel from each one and
they can hash it out in debate one how
would you improve the educational system
yourself and two
election that we have presidency that we
have to be a little bit more united sure
so let me uh just explain the the unity
2020 structure so people understand why
I bothered
Unity 2020 was an attempt to use a game
theoretic perspective to solve the
problem of the duopoly so we can't
escape the problem of the duopoly
because anytime you try to escape it you
tend to empower the force on the other
side right in other words if you if you
tend towards progressivism and you put
forward something that's actually
Progressive you'll divide the Democrats
and you will give power to the
Republicans so the the problem of the
Lesser evil is the thing that keeps us
locked in and unity 2020 proposed a
structure in which a liberal and a
conservative would team up and would
co-president this is all possible within
the confines put out by the Constitution
the President and Vice President could
flip a coin to see who ran at the top of
the ticket and then they could agree to
switch who was at the top of the ticket
after four years when they ran for
re-election and in the meantime they
could govern uh by consensus in other
words the two of them would sit down for
each policy decision
and they would hash out what the right
direction to go would be for the country
and only in the case where they couldn't
reach agreement with the person who was
in the top office have to make that
decision or in the case where there
wasn't time for them to confer so the
point is that formally solves the
problem of the Lesser evil because it
doesn't award either side extra power
and my contention is that really if you
had I mean imagine look look at who's
currently in the presidency and who the
last president was and go backwards
through history it's been quite a while
since we've had somebody who was really
effective in that office
and my point is we would be far better
off if we had people who were courageous
capable and patriotic right if you offer
me somebody who meets those three
criteria I don't actually care which
side of the what was the second one uh
courageous capable Patriot those are the
three and if you take two of those
people one from each side I'm pretty
comfortable that two people who come
from different sides of the aisle and
have those three characteristics who sit
down and have a a conversation about
what the right direction for the country
would be will arrive at something that I
can respect they might be wrong that
will happen this is a difficult puzzle
to solve but I know it won't be born of
corruption or ineptitude or how do you
avoid that though I mean it's very to
say you know if we have somebody that's
courageous okay people would vouch for
that somebody was capable fantastic
somebody who was patriotic phenomenal
uh how do you how do you how do you
manage that because the system can't
filter those three things out an actor
can become a president based on our
current system that we have well let's
um let's take our mutual friend Joe
Rogan for example and I don't mean to
put him on the spot here but can we
agree that he meets my three criteria no
question about no question yeah okay so
let's say that Joe Rogan is the uh the
progressive in uh in a Unity kind of
team
okay what does Joe do does Joe know
anything about how to architect a
civilization no not a skill set no but
what would he do
bring in the best of the best there you
go how hard is that no no I'm not I'm
not saying with you dad I I'm not
telling you I don't want a courageous
capable patriotic person what I'm saying
is why isn't the system
attracting those types of people to
become president and now somebody from
the right may say you're saying Trump
isn't courageous he is he's not capable
he's built businesses he's not patriotic
he loves America right somebody may say
you know Bill Clinton may fit that
quality or John F Kennedy may fit that
quality and I don't know who your last
capable president would have been in
your eyes do you have somebody they
think was the last capable one well
let's put it this way I don't want
anything to rest on whether or not my
evaluation of somebody's characteristics
is accurate I could be fooled by
somebody but yes I think there are there
are people I mean you know again Joe
Rogan meets those criteria easily I
would say Tulsi gabbard seems to meet
those criteria
um uh looks to me like Rand Paul meets
those criteria so uh there are lots of
people your question about why such
people don't tend to end up and I
wouldn't say it's that they don't tend
to end up attracted to the idea of
governing they don't tend to survive
that's my question not not attractive
because Tulsi did Rand did Joe doesn't
want to have anything to do with it at
least that's my uh understanding because
he's too smart yeah he's too smart but
but that's also the thing a lot of times
you know I had Catherine Gill I don't
know if you know who she is or Michael
Porter they wrote a book called the
industry of politics so I had them on
uh four years ago I don't know the exact
timeline I had them on a few years ago
and uh uh both of them lean left but
they had this idea about how to elect a
president in a completely different way
it's a model that's more on Andrew Yang
the direction he's going with forward
party and he's also kind of pushing a
third party person to get elected but a
Tulsa gabbard when she was on the left
and she said anything about Hillary
Clinton boom they oustered and now she's
out as an independent to win or Rand
Paul Rand has very good ideas a lot of
people from the right like Rand Paul
he's got audacity he's got courage he
went up against fauci he's not afraid he
has values he's got principles he stands
up for him he seems reasonable he seems
smart intellectual
but why the the current system doesn't
allow those types of talent to make it
to the top
Well it's worse than that
um our current system ensures that if
you make it to the uh the final round of
the competition that you are excellent
at corruption and that that's really the
problem is that you have an evolutionary
dynamic in which we are constantly
forcing the people who will ultimately
have that kind of power to demonstrate
that they are exceptionally good at
figuring out you know on which side
their bread is buttered and then when
they get to the top office we're shocked
that the corruption continues and so
another aspect of the the unity proposal
was that it effectively took courageous
capable Patriots and sped them past the
system that forces people to become
excellent at corruption now somebody who
had been sped past that corrupting uh
Steeplechase
would be in a position to purge the
system below them of corruption if you
try to do this from the ground up the
corruption will win if you did this from
the top down I'm not in general a fan of
top-down Solutions but in this case I
don't believe there's another way you
could do it if if this
you know hypothesis or a experiment
actually came to life this Unity party
this ticket correct me if I'm wrong
speaking of Andrew Yang I believe your
proposal was Andrew Yang on the left and
general bill mcraven on the right I want
to say in 2020 that was the initial
formulation of it so if that came to be
it's a two-part question how do you
think that governance would look today
2023 and you know you call yourself a
progressive almost even a radical your
words that to me sounds as moderate as
it gets meaning someone on the center
left someone on the center right come
together I guess maybe it's not moderate
as you're shaking your head I guess how
would they be faring today if that
ticket did come to life and what what
the moderate versus radical approach be
um that's a great question so I will say
I am a radical because I believe only
radical change can save us but it's not
like I like radicalism I don't like
radicalism I don't you are radical but
you don't like the concept I'm a radical
because in 2023 that's what's required I
don't want to see a radical civilization
I want to see a civilization in which
the tension between conservatism and
progressivism results in dynamism which
we've seen I mean that's what Built
America and the West dynamism it is that
tension right what you need is
progressives who can see what Solutions
actually might be worth the freight and
you need conservatives to put the brakes
on them to make sure they don't get
carried away with fanciful Notions about
what might be that our utopian nonsense
right it's both things so I you know I
have I have said sometimes in the past
that I am a a radical who wants to live
in a world so good that I get to be a
conservative right
so some some may say you sound confused
right they may and then they're not
getting it because you know and this is
one of the problems I see on the left is
that people fall in love with the idea
of progress they don't understand how
dangerous it is and so the point is we
we can't reach a place where they'll
stop right we can't reach a place that's
good enough that they will they will
stand down and say all right how do you
know we've succeeded how do we keep it
how about this just to be clear if you
could send a clear message clear concise
message to your friends on the far left
and then a clear concise message to the
friends on the far right about this
Unity ticket what would your direct
message to these types of people be
uh I think the message is if you don't
break out of the dynamic that you're
stuck in then this is going to be a
short ride
we we don't have a good plan to go
forward and we need one and frankly
we're 30 years late
right we needed to see this 30 years ago
then we would have had time to do this
now we're in an emergency situation and
I would just say it is as much as I see
um
conservatives have completely lost
patience with liberals and they've done
this because the Liberals at the moment
seem insane and so I would I would ask
them to rethink that and just recognize
that this is actually the moment at
which conservatives have a very clear
and vitally important role to play but
it is not to the exclusion of
progressives what what do conservatives
uh lose you so if for them to get
somebody like to where do they lose you
what what would they need to do to get
you
um the number one thing
is conservatives need to understand that
the environmental crisis is not
synonymous with climate change that we
have a clear environmental crisis what
we are doing to the planet cannot be
undone ever and so we must figure out
how to stop doing it and that's true
irrespective of the reality or fiction
involved in climate change and I'm
pretty convinced there is both so that's
one what else where else do they lose
you
um the idea that we
should return to a prior state with
respect to uh
how we deal with each other socially
right so there's a recognition that
something has gone very wrong for
example in the relationship between the
Sexes that's simply true it's gone very
wrong but we can't go back there's
nowhere to go back to right things began
to change radically at the I mean we
can't go back to be specific so when
you're saying they want to go back to
what do they want to go back to a
traditional relationship between men and
women and there are aspects of a
traditional relationship that I think
ought to be resurrected but there's we
can't go back because what changed our
circumstances was the introduction of
reliable birth control
that was the thing that changed and
everything else are it's sort of a
cascading set of
dysfunctions that have Arisen Downstream
of that because what it did is it
removed the central logic of the system
and I'm not claiming that the central
logic of the system was fair I don't
think it was but the central logic of
the system was reliable and had been
reliable literally for
well there's an argument to be made for
hundreds of millions of years right the
reality of male and female and the
relationship between those two phenomena
had had some consistency for hundreds of
millions of years it had certainly been
consistent for human history and
pre-history and then suddenly the
introduction of birth control Alters
that relationship in a fundamental way
and there was not the I mean there was a
certain amount of consternation over
what would happen but it wasn't
um I don't think it properly understood
that it was going to
rob the system of the incentive that had
driven civilization forward
so let's stay there okay so one uh uh
conservatives uh don't have climate
change as their priority is what you're
saying not climate change this is the
problem environmental sustainability
let's say okay when when conservatives
hear somebody say environment or
environmental crisis their mind
transmutes that into global warming
because this has become the the flagship
issue and the problem is conservatives I
believe are correct that they detect
nonsense around that issue that they are
being told something that is not a
complete story that where they're told
we must follow the science on climate
change we have an emergency and then the
science amounts to models that they
cannot evaluate they have the sense that
something is being smuggled in and I
don't think they're wrong about that
however that's not the same thing as
saying climate change isn't real and
important and more to the point
the issue of environmental
sustainability is a real issue
irrespective even if you found out that
climate change was a complete fiction
right it doesn't change the fact that we
are in an environmental crisis that
urgently needs our attention so those
are two different things though right
because what you're saying is one is I
don't know if conservatives are saying
that climate change is fake and it's a
hundred percent fabricated et cetera et
cetera when they're saying the money is
being used let's not you know fool
ourselves there's a lot of gaslighting
going on behind closed doors I mean did
you see the clip these guys had Rebel
news media did you see them interviewing
uh Greta Thon work did you see that fake
op-ed she did with the police and
Germany and that video and then this uh
have you seen this one or nowhere she's
you haven't seen this I'm aware that it
exists I'm trying not to process it too
much because I don't even know what it
is so so but the point is like she was
doing a picture like she got arrested
and she tweeted saying I got arrested by
the German police and then these guys at
Rebel news followed her if you can just
click on it I've got permission from
them they responded back to me he's
filming your arrest watch this
it's in Germany because it looked like
you did that in several takes didn't you
watch this you were posing with the
police
he's answering for you he's he's
answering for you he said you had an
agency what what I wish I had one it
would be much simpler then well who was
filming you then I don't know media you
don't know who is filming you in Germany
he said he knows he says it was an
agency
agency you idiots
do you normally have reporters defending
you
police and rwa fossil fuel company would
stage
how many how many times did you were you
arrested because you posed for several
times didn't you
sure
so so for example a that's not a
conservative that says why are you
making propaganda videos using a young
girl who's no longer young she's 19 or
20 years old right now I'm sorry I don't
like to be gaslighted that's not a
conservative thing I relate more to
libertarian philosophy but if I have to
choose between the two on who I vote for
I'm going to go on one side I think the
position from conservatives haven't
debated a lot haven't had a lot of these
guys on on that specific topic is look
we don't know
you know where the left says no we know
this is the number one crisis we're
dealing with and the conservatives are
saying we don't know for a fact you know
the the Earth's been around for a long
time how do you know for a fact how do I
know for a fact so let's keep that as a
discussion versus I know for a fact
right and then the second part you
talked about
uh on going back to uh you know uh
family well family nucleus you know
going back to traditional Family Values
birth control you know which 1950 kind
of changed the game when that came out
well sometimes uh uh you know I see that
as a test we do like I would assume as a
scientist I'm not a scientist but in we
run a company and we'll say Let's test
this comp plan
to see if it works and then all of a
sudden you're like oh discount plan
produces terrible results guys let's go
back to the old comp plan there is
nothing wrong with that you know when
you introduce a new compensation
structure or a new model or a new
segment or a new show and you're like
dude this is a terrible show we just
launched we did 10 of them already they
don't like it let's just cut it we're
not going to continue funding this show
what's wrong with saying this one area
we were willing to be gentle with and
open-minded to guess what it's not
producing the right results we got to go
back to the principles that produce
results so are we talking about climate
change or [__] second one not climate
change we're talking about uh family
Dynamics yes oh nothing's wrong with it
except that it's never going to happen
what do you mean by that what I mean is
prior to Reliable birth control
there was a structure that was imposed
on us by Nature
and again I'm not defending it as fair
but what it was was coherent
and that structure came from the fact
that human babies are incredibly
expensive to raise and I don't mean that
financially I mean the investment that
goes into a human baby is like no other
creature
what that means is that it requires more
than one person to raise one which then
means that a woman would be crazy if she
had a choice to choose to produce an
offspring that she would have to raise
alone if she had the option to raise it
with a partner
okay so it is that extreme cost which
Falls initially entirely on women that
they can then redistribute with a
partner
that cost drives the system
on the flip side of that
you have the fact that
sex for men is one of the
maybe it is the most potent motivator in
the universe there is nothing that tops
it and so in a world where women guard
their reproductive capacity carefully
because they do not want to accidentally
produce a child for which they will be
fully responsible for raising it
men have to live up to whatever standard
women set in order to be worthy of a
sexual relationship which is the
ultimate goal of the evolutionary
exercise
that was a coherent world not fair but
coherent
you introduce birth control in which sex
and reproduction are now technologically
separated from each other and that logic
no longer works now it took decades for
it to fully break down but we are at the
point where this logic has now given way
and young people do not inherently see
the logic of finding a partner they
don't inherently see the logic of
producing Offspring and while not having
a partner and not producing offspring
are valid choices I would defend
people's right to make those choices the
degree to which people have lost sight
of why they might want to do those
things should be alarming to us so is
your position pro-choice pro-life is is
that what you're saying as your second
one to make it a little bit more
specific for the audience I'm not really
advocating for a solution here we could
talk about what Solutions might be no no
a question I'm asking is like when I
said what what do conservatives need to
do to get your vote and you said number
one is sustainability the fact that they
don't even want to give the you know
where I said to you I think the left is
more certain that there's climate change
to write is just saying let's be
skeptical and let's be open to fact that
maybe there isn't maybe this is a
natural cycle the second one you said
how you know 1950 the birth control so
is is your second one saying that the
right is too convinced that it has to be
pro-life where it's pro-choice you know
this is a funny issue I have known for
since I started thinking about it
decades ago that there was vastly more
agreement on the issue of choice than we
acknowledge that our our discussion has
become extremely polarized but most
people fall out in a camp that is that
believes there is some right
to terminate a pregnancy very early
while we are talking about something
that is uh
has certainly the potential to become a
human but does not have the
characteristics of a a human yet and
people grow increasingly uncomfortable
the closer we get to the moment of birth
that's where almost all of us are now
there's a group of people
who has a religious perspective that I I
respect which says you're interfering in
a Divine process something has decided
to produce a child and you are deciding
to override it and that is the reason
that a certain brand of religious
conservative does not see any room for
uh for terminating a pregnancy but that
is a small fraction of the population
most of us believe there is some right
to that technology and that that right
grows less and less compelling the
closer we get to the moment of birth
okay so you know by and large I don't
I don't need
religious conservatives to give up their
commitment to their understanding of how
the universe works and frankly I think
the bias that this is a sobering
decision is the right one for sure but
you know how should
Society be governed well it should be
governed approximately where we all fall
out we're not overly comfortable with
this process but but we believe that it
has to exist in some form for lots of
reasons I mean
rape and incest being
an obvious an obvious case where for
most of us the idea that a rapist can
inflict a pregnancy on a woman and that
she has no right to end it is
preposterous
yeah that that uh that by the way that's
also where
uh conservatives are conflicted meaning
amongst each other so I don't know if
that makes sense like some of them are
from the standpoint of no even if it is
rape even if it is this even if it is
that you know you still got a dude which
you know that's
considered extremists if a person wants
to take that position and some say no
that's not the part I'm talking about
the part I'm talking about which by the
way I saw a joke the other day by a guy
I'm going to give this guy a shout out
Jeffrey asmus which I thought was was
very funny have you seen this one where
he gets up and he says I never
understood why conservatives or
Republicans are approach pro-life
he says Republicans should stay
pro-choice
he says you know why he says wait for it
it's going to take you five seconds to
get this he says why he says because
most kids that get aborted are liberals
did you get it yeah so you're sitting
there kind of thinking about it where
what a heavy joke right there because if
you think about who and what ethnicity
pro-choice Hurts the Most it's
you know most of the abortions in
America if you you can look at the data
you know the data already yourself
but okay so let's let's let's go past
this one let's go wait wait I think
there's one point that needs to be on
the table because I do know that
conservatives are conflicted amongst
themselves about this question and there
is a an argument that absolutely belongs
on the table in that argument what's
there in that context
the argument is they're actually has to
be a right for a woman who has been
raped to terminate that pregnancy and I
would hope that it happens as early as
possible for many reasons
the reason is an evolutionary one
if you create a scenario in which a
woman is forced to carry the product of
rape to the point of giving birth and
raising this child
you are opening up a strategy for
rapists to reproduce and the problem is
that that's extreme breath you're taking
a very extreme position in what way I
mean you so here's the part that that uh
both the left and the right does that
they uh take an argument that happens
less than one percent of the time and
they use that as the basis for the
argument on why a hundred percent of the
other side's position isn't right but
I'm not saying that but that's a very
small minute uh position you know in in
case that we're talking about why
tell us why because rape is not
something that is you know as if if we
take a hundred of the pregnancies that
happen yeah and we say well let's really
get some data on what caused these
pregnancies one night stands boyfriend
girlfriend didn't you know uh use a
condom uh you were on the dates you were
off you forgot to take the pill how
often do people forget to take the pill
there's a lot of kids that are born
because somebody forgot the Wednesday
pill or the Friday pill you know you got
somebody that just wants to have the
kids because the tax code benefits
somebody having kids and getting free
money from the government another one
could be let me lock up a guy who's got
money man if I have his baby he has to
pay me you know child support there's a
the tax code benefits
women getting pregnant
as a to a certain sect that do take
advantage of that system but to say rape
rape would be at the bottom of a very
low low small fraction let's keep it
that way that's my point is that if you
if you if you open the door to a
strategy in which a rapist who can
trigger a pregnancy can have we can
basically force a woman to give birth to
that child and in most cases to raise it
what you are doing is you are inviting a
future in which rape is more common
right because it becomes a viable
evolutionary I don't I don't I don't
know if I uh
I don't know if I agree with that
because there's there's two things to it
the forget about the viable strategy
one of the strategies of raping is
you're going to jail okay so so the the
crime the punishment you know we can
make that more severe where in certain
cities in America it's not treated that
way certain cities in America it's kind
of like wow you know he's okay let's
give him a second chance third chance
four chance there's a lot of cities in
America that have rapists walking around
because they're forgiving rapists that's
not the fact that we're saying let's
keep the baby if you're raped by a man
that's because of the laws are forcing
some people to say I can get away with
murder and rape well I would certainly
support
stronger laws in cases where you
actually prove a you know stranger rape
is the case that we're talking about
here then my sense is somebody who would
engage in that doesn't you know doesn't
really deserve a second chance if you're
capable of that what are the chances
that when you get out of prison you're
gonna you know do it again be a uh yeah
the chances you're going to do it again
are high but the fraction of rapes that
are actually successfully prosecuted is
low and so both things are true yes by
driving the penalty up for somebody who
gets caught you can reduce the viability
of the strategy but not sufficiently and
so all I'm saying as an evolutionist I
know that I know it's a rough argument
but the argument is you don't want this
strategy to be a winner I don't think I
don't think conservatives are going to
be sitting there supporting that but the
the question then becomes too so so flip
it so you got two sides here as a person
who is you and your wife
Evergreen you're the top Prof your
wife's the top Professor you're right
behind her top Professor so essentially
you guys are the top two professor in
school 15 years you got a 16 year old
you got an 18 year old I think it's fair
to say your kids are not going to go to
Evergreen is that a pretty a good
assessment right there no they won't be
here
but but here's a part as a parent
announced different when you're a 29
year old Progressive versus a 44 year I
don't know your age but I'm assuming
we're the same age 44 year old
Progressive yeah I'm 53 but well great
you you look good
so okay so a 53 year old Progressive you
know your your Optics have changed
you're looking at it from your kids
you're seeing how you were treated
you're seeing how maybe you were even on
their side and arguing on their uh side
now you're sitting there saying listen
you know certain things in life of
values are no longer the same what I
used to vote for that was number one
that was number 13 what I voted for was
number two and I was 28 but what I
thought it was number 17 is now number
two what's what is what are your top uh
three four five reasons on to say I
think this party has what I support and
I think this party does what are the top
four five things you vote for
well I should tell you neither of these
parties are viable they're both so
deeply corrupt that uh I don't see
um I don't see either of them being
resurrected in some form and you know
again this is this is exactly why I say
reluctant radical
we are now at a place that we have to
radically alter this system in order for
there to be a system at all 200 years
from now
and I care very deeply about this I do
have two kids as you point out and I'm
very concerned about what world they are
emerging into and what will they will
produce children in
um so I wish I wish I could say look
here's what you need to do to fix the
Republican Party here's what you would
have to do to get the Democrats back on
track this is too far gone right this is
these are both influence peddling
rackets and we suffer from it daily I
mean and I know it's a very dangerous
topic
but I don't think we're ever going to
get a better peek at how the system
really works than looking at the
pandemic that we have just experienced
right that's the quality of governance
that we've got it's not good enough to
manage a species playing with tools as
powerful as the ones that we have it's
just not going to work
can I ask just one follow-up before we
go down to the next topic I just wanted
to revisit what you basically said about
birth control and because it's very high
on your list on essentially it's what
intersectional Dynamics how men and
women operate together from a human
evolutionary standpoint my question is
this you know you kind of use the the
metaphor of the gas and the brakes with
the progressives and the conservatives
kind of reigning in like listen relax
pump the brakes a little bit
progressives are bringing up ideas
conservatives yeah not too much so to
use that concept of birth control you
said that for men sex is the most potent
motivation in the universe and women
birth control I believe it was right
around 1950 where that was introduced to
society and women kind of had their
their ability to choose who are going to
have partners with you know the argument
of hypergamy and all that
um my question is this you said that um
you know women essentially are The
Gatekeepers of sex men will do what the
women tell them to do and it's it's at
the point now where uh you know the
toothpaste is out of the tube or the
Genies out of the bottle women have
birth control they're fighting for the
rights we saw what happened in the
midterms it's supposed to be a red wave
all of a sudden they try to you know
take away abortion rights boom all of a
sudden it's not a red wave not
whatsoever women have this choice now so
my question is this you said it's too
late to go back to essentially a make
America great again concept or whatever
that was or traditional women these days
you kind of highlighted this is one of
the biggest problems in society today is
women having the option of birth control
and aborting baby you're just not having
the baby altogether the morning after
pill what Solutions can be brought to
the table now I know you say didn't have
all the solutions but you know women
aren't going back in the kitchen they're
working they're making more money than
ever they're liberated many of them are
though many of them are uh but they
extend but changing but I will tell you
this but I will tell you this let's you
you're saying that because results are
now okay so there are some things that
takes a couple decades to test has to
know doesn't work this is one of the
reasons why I didn't take the test
because I'm like I've taken a lot of
different vaccines who have Decades of
tests trials five ten years I don't
trust nine months of testing right fair
enough so to say you know women are not
going back I don't know if I agree with
that because I think a lot of people are
sitting there saying
I tested this I'm 52 years old single
making 180 Grand and I'm miserable I
wish I would have gotten married I wish
I would have had a different situation
so the results on who is happier today
isn't the
185 year old female executive not
married no kids you know market value
isn't the same and having to choose on
who to date you know it's not the same
anymore so this is not everybody I'm not
telling you everybody some of them are
going that direction because a woman
powered this woman powered that but the
way we judge uh the you know as as at
least I'm speaking for myself is there
are a lot of things that we're certain
about not a lot of things we're certain
about most things we're not certain
about most things were skeptical about
this is why when I asked Neil deGrasse
Tyson I said tell me about debate he
says I don't believe in debate I don't
like debate well I like debate because a
lot of times I sit there and I look at
things and I'm like
maybe this is the right direction we're
doing maybe this is the right thing that
we're doing I don't know let me get the
data interesting that's an interesting
point he makes she makes a very good
point and then 5 10 15 20 years oh [__]
that was a terrible experiment then I
was a part of it and I was I lived 20
years in this experiment but we're gonna
know this is not the right thing we did
okay so you were going to ask a question
well I fundamentally do agree with what
you're saying that in general there
there's in society there's need of
Corrections and sometimes there's over
corrections I think what's happening in
this instance with birth control is
there was a correction in women's rights
and feminism all great but there's
clearly been an over correction where
it's like all right women have gone off
the deep end and so in some regards of
being too liberal and have the ability
to do way too much like you're saying
the traditional woman I guess what's
your your take on this and what what can
be improved uh in in gender relations
because I believe that's how you started
this all right um You Do remind me of
Neil deGrasse Tyson and your question
about education let's return to that
afterwards but
um I wouldn't
phrase it that way what I would say is
that there were spectacular benefits to
the consequences of birth control
The Liberation of women is a Triumph
right you had a a one of the Sexes was
hobbled in its ability to contribute to
the most interesting parts of building a
society because of its disproportionate
responsibility reproductively
birth control freed women
to do all of the most amazing stuff
involved in Being Human other than
producing children
the costs of that however have been
spectacular and so this is why I say we
can't go back what are the costs though
well
we used to move mountains and we moved
mountains based on the fact that the
system was coherent so men used to move
mountains why well in part to become
worthy of women worth partnering with
right that was the logic of the system
and it put men on the moon you take that
logic out because now sex has become
mundane
and we aren't the same people that we
were we're not as good to each other we
are not moving in the right direction
the coherence in the system you don't
think so you don't think uh you don't
think we are uh
good to each other
what what kind what uh uh Intel or study
shows that we're not good to each other
well I mean let's put it this way I
don't want to pretty up the past
obviously there was lots of terrible
stuff including lots of lineage against
lineage stuff that was for at least a
few decades definitely waning it may be
returning now but yes I think at the
moment we're being terrible to each
other we don't is that are we really not
being are we really being terrible to
each other are we being told that we're
being terrible to each other those are
two different two different things we
are being induced to be terrible to each
other we're being induced to being
terrible to each other yeah can you
unpack that please sure
um let us take the I mean you can take
any of these issues in which we find
ourselves so very polarized you know you
can take the abortion issue we're really
not that far apart in terms of you know
what people say to each other over the
dinner table about what they believe but
you know politically it's unresolvable
issue likewise you know everything that
happened over you know covid you were
either you know Pro mask Pro vax
anti-early treatment you know or the
inverse right that that was nonsense the
fact is this was a complex system in
which we all had a shared interest in
figuring out what was going on but we
could barely even stand each other right
that's the commonplace uh thing that we
see on almost every issue and so I don't
think uh how it works I don't know but
that it functions to keep us back on our
heels so that we are incapable of uh
moving in a coherent direction is clear
it is serving somebody's interests it is
protecting something that has power and
has everything to lose if we are able to
uh you know find our humanity and move
forward as as uh as one people right I
mean that's we're supposed to do that
that's what patriotism is we're supposed
to love our country and we're supposed
to figure out how to govern it and we're
going to make mistakes and we're
supposed to be honest about what they
were and figure out how to do better in
the future but we're incapable of that
because we're now divided into teams
right we are loyal to a jersey we've
always been divided you know and I think
that's uh
that's natural for us always like hey
um Team smoking weed I'm not I'm team
going to church I don't believe in God
I'm team Lakers I'm team Clippers I'm
team uh UFC I'm team football I'm team
you know that's what makes us awesome
that's what makes us unique the part
that I think we're Brit we kind of fell
for the Trap is uh my wife is right now
going through the Journey of health and
she's like the other day four
documentaries back to back to back to
back to back and she's sitting there
looking at documentaries from both sides
one documentary is executive producer
Leonardo DiCaprio the solution to the
world is we all have to be vegans you
know the other documentary is food Inc
look what big business in you know in
the food industry is doing big food is
catastrophic what they're doing and how
they're manipulating food what they're
putting in it and we're buying into it
right because it's a business model
right even with big Pharma there's big
food there's big Pharma there's big a
lot of things going on
and then there's big media media's job
is for us to hate each other the more
there's conflict the more there's
challenge they figured it out the more
money they make the more we're divided
the more there's an enemy the more
there's the monster the more there's you
better be careful the more there's look
at World economic Forum got together to
tell ourselves an extraterrestrial you
know crisis we're facing and we're
wondering if ET is showing up you know
because the first thing I think about is
ET phone home what are we doing they
contacted ET and we don't I mean what is
but people are buying into this [__]
and they're falling for this trap so but
behind closed doors dude I'm sick I've
got a lot of people I sit down with we
disagree with we have great
conversations and you know one could be
a Muslim I'm a Christian I say listen
man you have to understand that you
don't know what you're talking about but
we walk away and having great drinks
together great food together maybe they
don't have the drinks but we have great
food together but the point is this the
point I'm trying to make is
I don't know if we are as divided as
we're being told we are
I don't know if we are you're Maybe I'm
Wrong no you're you're right and in fact
there was a very interesting study a few
years back called The Hidden tribes
report in which they actually went
through it and they found that there
were really uh five coalitions but that
the majority of us exist in a large what
they called the exhausted middle right
where we basically agree on things and I
I believe this is absolutely true this
is also matched my experience of talking
to people I always try to talk to people
who are you know people I'm not supposed
to be able to relate to and it's amazing
how much basis there is for us to get
along
the problem though and you know you you
hit on it rather directly
we are built to compete right Evolution
this is the most fundamental aspect of
evolution is competition it's how we
became great and so our tendency to
compete with each other is the engine
that drives the system the problem is or
one of them is that the competition has
been between lineages
and it has built everything
right it is our attempt to get ahead of
each other that has caused us to
discover all of the things that have
made us powerful and insightful
we can't keep doing it
right the lineage against lineage
competition has to end because our tools
are now so powerful that if we continue
playing that game it will be our lineage
against lineage meaning I'm black
against white
um you know uh Asian against middle
you're talking about like
yeah I'm avoiding the word race because
race is a bastardization of the real
concept well we're not what we're not
again I don't think we're doing that
because I I I see uh uh more white
people marry and black people I see more
Hispanics Marian Middle Eastern there's
a famous comedian Tehran shout out to
Tehran black Persian comedian his name
is Tehran the capital of Iran but he's
black can you pull up what Tehran looks
like if you saw Tehran in the streets
you would never call him Tehran you
would call him maybe Tyrone but not
Tehran and that's what Tehran is and
he's funny I like him a lot I saw this
guy years ago and he's still at it doing
a great job but I'm seeing more people
that are in a racial relationships and
it's happening on both sides by the way
you go to Christians you go to atheists
you go to all Sites that's happening
maybe not as much on the Muslim side
because a lot of times Muslims marry
Muslims or even Indians will never but
even that that has opened up a little
bit where they were going through you
know hey arranged marriage and that was
back in the 70s and 80s some families
are still doing it but it's only 25 as a
ranged marriage where used to be 100
we're becoming a little bit more
understanding to say hey we got a lot of
things in common you and I may disagree
on eight things but dude we agree on 92
things so let's kick it let's have a
great conversation and let's debate the
eight things we disagree with maybe we
only come down to four or three or two
but that but but I still think
the lineage part is probably less today
than before again it goes back to the
media is telling us we're racist the
media is telling us you're a white
supremacist the Evergreen Professor who
doesn't want all he wants to do is a all
whites meeting and other people are not
invited and how dare you you better kick
them out and then the school have to pay
you and your wife a quarter million a
piece or whatever the number was that
they had to settle with they have to pay
you guys right for what they did so I
don't I don't know about that I think we
are more and more uh uh uh open like
when I was dating girls and my dad one
day sister look you I would like to
assume Marion Assyrian or Armenian
I said that very slim chance that's
going to be happening okay it's most
likely going to be a black girl because
that's what most of my girlfriends were
or it's going to be Hispanic or it's
going to be somebody else
but maybe end up being Middle Eastern
well ended up being a white girl from
Texas okay and we got four kids we fight
we do our best to be happy we try to
make our family work
do we agree on everything no but I think
we collectively dose stories need to be
told rather than these [__] stories
that is
by the way the ratings are showing
Americans are sick of that philosophy
the ratings if we if we if we gauged
whether we're divided or not bred the
ratings would show we're getting more
and more united because we want to watch
less and less of CNN and MSNBC because
they're getting crushed we want to watch
less and less of Jimmy Fallon and Jimmy
Kimmel because they're making fun of
people that disagree with them and we're
more likely to just stop it man where is
the Jay Leno days where the you know
Letterman days or Johnny Carson days too
much gamesmanship we don't want to do it
anymore I think we're making progress
again I may be wrong and I'm just seeing
it from one lens but I actually think
we're making more progress towards being
united than being divided if we turn on
too much TV we are being divided if we
don't we just kind of talk to people
we're a little more united
all right let me try this from an
evolutionary framework please
lineage against lineage competition is
what forced us to become so capable the
reason that our our brains are so
disproportionately large compared to
other creatures has to do with out
thinking each other right we've been in
an arms race and it has made us all
smart
that tendency
manifests as racism throughout much of
History you are absolutely right that
that thing was
disappearing rapidly for most of my life
everybody knew that it wasn't a good
thing and what where we are is we are in
a tension between two valid evolutionary
reasons to collaborate
one of them has to do with genes that's
the lineage versus lineage thing the
other has to do with reciprocity
right when we put aside genes and we
collaborate with somebody because they
have some insight that we don't have and
by partnering we get emergence where the
sum is greater the whole is greater than
the sum of the parts
that is a much better way of competing
the problem is the gene-based
competition is more fundamental right it
has existed longer
so as we lose touch with the fact that
we are all actually jeopardized by the
same things and we would all benefit by
heading in the same direction we
break down into that tribal mode
and that is where we are right we are
being divided we went through a period
in which it's not like racism had
disappeared but it was disappearing
rapidly and now it's back with a
vengeance
you are right people are sick of it and
so they are now defaulting into
demonizing people for other stuff right
maybe it's not the color of your skin
but it's the fact that you're
unvaccinated and you're putting Grandma
at risk right so that desire to see the
world as us and Them is still haunting
us and we have to get past it because
the future will be very Bleak if that's
the driving force the future that we
need is the one that the West figured
out which was put aside the gene stuff
collaborate because it's a good way of
getting ahead
right that Melting Pot idea is the thing
to be resurrected and I'm concerned that
we are seeing it break down we are not
tending it and it is falling apart in
front of our eyes
can I ask just a very simple question
um you know back in the day it was maybe
people your age are a little bit older
the boomers are are you a baby I am not
a book okay your Gen X yes apologize how
dare you man we went from 44 to 65. I'm
sorry he looks great again I'll revisit
this head of hair you and your brother
have it I don't know not only are you
the client you're the player president
of the the Hair Club but anyway the
Boomers were kind of responsible for
Woodstock changing the system and then
you can go back a generation before that
whether it was a silent generation
traditionalist these days here's my
question when you you know the face of
wokeness and the face of you know all
this super progressiveness at the end of
the day our college campus liberals
20-something-year-olds gen Z is this
sort of just every generation the young
people are going to have their causes
they identify with and it is what it is
and they're the future sorry 68 year old
72 year olds 80 year olds it's not your
time has come and gone and move on it's
now gen Z time the woke time how much of
that is just on them and this is their
philosophy and they're the future and
it's like it is what it is Buddy how
much of that is on them
uh I wish unfortunately it's on us and
you know this actually is a perfect way
to get back to your question about uh
education
problem or at least I would argue one of
the most major problems is that we have
broken the mechanism by which young
people come to understand how the world
functions
now that has happened in a number of
different ways but it has accelerated
very rapidly in the last decade or two
because of the iPhone I'm assuming in
the internet
it could have been a lot of things it
happened to be those two and a few more
um you know porn lots of stuff but the
the problem if you think back into what
human beings fundamentally are
human beings are a creature in which you
have the hardware package the body and
you have a software package that is
loaded in after the child is born
primarily
that software package
is capable of turning you into anything
you can be an Inuit hunting large sea
mammals by kayak right or you can be a
Maasai herdsman or you can be a
collector of swallow nests in a cave in
China right a human being can be a lot
of different things based on what
software package it gets right it can be
an Aztec
um
but what it cannot do is live in a world
where by the time an individual becomes
an adult the software program that it
picked up in childhood is already
obsolete there is no mechanism to deal
with that world where it is changing so
rapidly that the world you're born into
is gone before you become an adult and
that's the world that we're living in in
our case it happens to surround
Technologies like iPhones like the
internet like pornography these things
are radically altering the realities
and this then brings us back to the
question of what would we what should we
do to fix education and the
the answer at least a big part of it
is actually staring Us in the face
what
is so distorting about the technologies
that come to us through screens is that
they are not obligated to adhere to
rules
right on the internet if you say that
you're a woman then I guess you are
right because who's going to say
differently right in reality if you're a
man and you say that you're a woman
there's something to talk about right
that doesn't appear that doesn't match
the person I see standing in front of me
so the way to
take a generation and
educate it so that it does not grow up
to be
um a world full of suckers is to force
education to include
things that are obligated to rules
especially physical rules
so when Heather and I were teaching
among the things that we did was we
would assign students to teach
themselves any skill right we had an
assignment we we called learn a skill
and the idea was it didn't matter what
skill it was but it had one requirement
the skill had to be one where you didn't
need some person to tell you whether you
had succeeded or failed it had to be
obvious if you were going to build
tables they had to stand up they had to
be level right you don't need someone to
tell you you did or you didn't build a
table right you didn't or you didn't fix
an engine you did or you didn't play a
song that sounded musical right those
are all physical realities and the
reason that that is so important
is that in a world where everything that
you learn is learned socially right you
can be persuaded of things that are
absolutely false right if the professor
at the front of the room is a fool
but they are in charge of your grade and
they say lots of foolish things and you
dutifully write them down in your
notebook and then you spit them back out
on the test you are being anti-educated
right that's never going to happen in
the context of an engine or a garden or
anything where it's physics that
dictates whether or not you succeeded or
it's biology that dictates whether or
not you've succeeded so my point would
be somebody who gets really good at
operating in the physical world is not
going to be a fool right they may you
know lack some skills they may not be
able to do calculus they may not be
articulate but they won't be a fool and
so we have to include these mechanisms
that are not socially conveyed in our
education at a high level and frankly
most people can go through school and
never encounter these things they're no
longer a part of the regular curriculum
would you do us a favor and go maybe
slightly deeper and take a sort of an
abstract idea and be very specific like
what are you doing with with your 16 and
18 year old kids to educate them so they
don't become fools and victims of modern
society you know we do all kinds of
things we troubleshoot our vehicles when
they fail we
build additions onto our house we fix
the plumbing when it's not working and
you know these things they're not only
incredibly useful but they're also
rewarding right there's nothing quite
like taking something that isn't working
for reasons that are mysterious going
through the process which by the way
ends up being a scientific process where
you determine what it is that must be
going wrong with it and then you
discover hey I must have had that right
because there it is working now right
that's a very rewarding process it's
very interesting because you I would say
you know obviously you get paid to use
your brain in your mouth but you're
making your kids use their hands to
accomplish things that must be very
intentional well it isn't it is you know
I sort of grew up as a tinkerer I was
always when people would come to do work
on the house I grew up in I would follow
them around like a puppy dog watching
everything they did understanding how
the house worked and and all of those
things and so you know it's it's not
like I have to go out of my way to teach
this lesson it's it's intuitive but it
also it works like gangbusters some may
say you're just getting free labor out
of your kids I don't know that is
definitely also the case let's talk
about let's transition to a couple
different topics this has been great uh
we got 45 minutes left and we got a few
topics to go through so Chad gbt is
passing the tests required for medical
licenses and business degrees I don't
know if you saw this or not pull up a
little bit so we can kind of cover this
so the viral chat bot that has race
concerns from teachers and academics
over its ability to cheat on essays and
exam has now passed a Wharton NBA final
exam the United States medical licensing
exam and components of the bar exam and
this thing's only been around since
November by the way the war A Wharton
Professor conducted a study in which he
used open AI gp3
gpt3 uh the language model on which it
is built on to take a final example of a
core MBA course it concluded that gpt3
would have received a b to B minus on
the exam the professor Christian
tarawish founded that gpt3 performed the
best at basic operations management and
processing analysis questions for these
the chatbot provided both correct
answers an excellent explanation as to
why an answer was selected in the paper
summary
teacher acknowledged that the gpt3 is by
no means perfect at times he the bot
made mistakes and simple mathematical
calculations and wasn't able to handle
more advanced process analysis questions
the study further fueled the
conversation that academics are now
having as a result of gpt3 GPT Advanced
writing skills regarding exam policies
Etc so some professors are extremely
concerned some are worried some are
saying this could question the existing
business model teaching model
universities How concerned are you how
excited are you how little do you care
about this
um I don't think anybody is worried
enough I think the hazard of what we're
facing is almost beyond what we can
imagine and that is I'm saying that even
though
I know I know what you have to focus on
if you want to comfort yourself that
this isn't so terrible
um you know you can focus on the fact
that this model has no capacity to be
conscious right it's it's simulating
meaning without knowing what it's saying
but I don't know how long that lasts I
do know that this is a pretty good spot
check of where we are in the uh
trajectory that results in uh General
artificial intelligence
and I don't think we are remotely ready
for what's coming
and I will I will point to the you know
the
the most obvious of these problems is
already already critical and you're
you're hinting at it in what you're
reading here but the fact that
it is going to become extremely
difficult to assess actual competence
is it should alarm us at the highest
level right to have a the possibility
you could have a conference of people
all Consulting whatever descendant of uh
chat GPT happens to be available at the
time and talking to each other as if
they know what they're talking about you
know we've already got a problem with
our experts who don't mostly seem to
know what they're talking about this is
going to be you know a hundred times as
bad in a world where they can be
Consulting something that sounds very
knowledgeable and May in fact be
completely on the wrong track which I
would point out is another argument and
maybe even a much stronger argument for
including
real world physical interactions in
which you do not have to assess whether
or not somebody knows what they're doing
they either fixed your engine or they
didn't right it either runs or it or it
doesn't those kinds of things are not
going to be easily fixed though even
they right a mechanic who does not know
what he's doing but is able to consult
this device in order to figure out what
is likely causing a problem is going to
become less and less capable so
I don't know what we're supposed to do
about it but I do know we're not ready
we're not ready and the rate at which
this is going to get better is clear
right exposing it to larger and larger
data sets is going to make it better and
better at at simulating this kind of
interaction and that's you know that's
if it stays unconscious
the question of what happens if this
doesn't stay unconscious or this stays
unconscious but it's descendant picks up
Consciousness is even more troubling and
I I
but but go okay go to ugly Place good
bad ugly worst case what happens
is it the fear that uh
um I actually want you to go there
before I tell you what I think is the
fear for some people okay
first of all we don't need
chat GPT to take us to the worst case
scenario we are already losing our
capacity to understand the world we live
in to manage the tools that we are
creating to live in harmony with each
other we are losing those things in the
present prior to chat GPT
all of those problems get worse this is
like an accelerant right this is like
you had a house fire and then you just
threw gasoline on it right now we have a
raging house fire so I don't know that
this is or isn't the thing but I do know
it's not going to help at this moment we
can't deal with this and this is not the
last time that's going to happen by the
way right we had a world we had an
internet
and then we dumped smartphones into it
and it was like an accelerant it took
the um the derangement that was arising
out of natural algorithmic processes
within the internet and they got vastly
worse when people were constantly
confronted with their phone and the
ability to interact in this way all the
time so we've seen that we're going to
see it again with fusion power fusion
power which I believe is
the one technology that
potentially
bootstraps us out of the system we're in
and into one that is sustainable but if
you just added it to the system tomorrow
if you read the paper tomorrow and
turned out we'd accomplished scalable
Fusion it would likely make things worse
and not better because we're not ready
for the world that it creates so I don't
know what the name of that problem is
but that we're not ready for that
problem is a very serious one and we can
swap in one technology after another and
you know it will create different
disasters what's the most dangerous
invention we ever had
is the most dangerous invention ever the
most dangerous invention we ever had or
innovation invention Innovation was the
most dangerous invention where we
invented it we're like oh [__] this is
not good
you know it's an almost impossible
question to answer because you know if I
if I do the if I do the job right it'll
probably be something like
paper or
the mirror right those things kick loose
processes that may drive our Extinction
in the end right they won't you know
there's not going to be a mirror the day
the president hits the nuclear button
and it all goes up in smoke right but
the point is it may be the kind of
self-awareness that comes when you see a
photorealistic impression of yourself
you know two feet away right it may be
that the thought processes that follow
from that are the reason that we will
ultimately destroy ourselves
um
more approximately of course we do have
to talk about things like nuclear
weapons
boy do I think we just got a wake-up
call on the
um the biology front with covid I mean
yeah this was a lot a lot better than it
might have been but this is the first
round and
um
we did not we did not do very well with
this test let's put it that way okay so
we're going to get to that here in a
minute let's stay on this topic of the
most dangerous invention you said it
could be the mirror or paper but
probably nuclear is where we're going to
go or you know other things right when I
say paper I'm really hinting at written
language of course this is of course
also you know incredibly marvelous I'm
not arguing it's not fantastic so so if
if
guns when guns were first invented they
called them the great equalizer who were
they good for who were they bad for
well this is one of the these places
where I have uh changed my perspective
um I long believed the second amendment
was the greatest error in our
constitution I no longer believe that
and that doesn't mean that I look
past all of the terrible unnecessary
Carnage that arises because guns are
easily available but I'm watching
tyranny erupt in places that I never
would have expected it and I am
wondering if the founders did not very
wisely understand that this day would
come and that it will be very hard for
tyrants to
um succeed in America if the populace
is armed so again I don't I don't I know
people will hear something in that that
I'm not saying the cost of having these
weapons commonly available is huge and
frankly completely unacceptable to me
really so the costs are so you're you
went from pro-second amendment to now
saying it would be better if we didn't
have guns no no the other way yeah I'll
say yeah so now the benefit of having it
is good versus not having it even though
I appreciate the tremendous unnecessary
cost of these weapons being common right
even though I see that cost I believe
nothing is will be more destructive than
if tier irony I mean we've already seen
lots of hints of tyranny in in recent
times in the U.S but if tyranny takes
over
our our nation and the West yeah we are
in even more serious trouble so I
believe the harms that do come from
these weapons being common will be
dwarfed by the harms of uh things like
what we've you know what we saw in the
20th century in the Soviet Union for
example so let's go back right now in
Iran yeah so let's go back to the
question so uh who the invention of gun
the great equalizer who did it hurt who
did it benefit
um I think I don't want to pretend to be
an expert on that question it would take
me a lot of thought to to get to an
answer right I I believe this is this is
what happens when you ask a former
professor of evolutionary biology very
rarely very rarely do I have an answer
more than a evolutionary biology
scientist okay but who did it hurt and
who did it benefit I think who it hurt
the most were bullies right people that
could just strong arm you physically or
in any capacity and who did it help it
helped weaker people sometimes you might
say the weaker sex it helped women
um I think at the end of the day if if
there's two very strong people a man and
a woman or a weaker man and a very
strong man yeah and all of a sudden the
weaker person has a gun
essentially that's the great equalizer
so I think it hurt bullies the most and
if you extrapolate that to governments
and you take a look at you know bully
governments whether it's Iran today with
the moolahs whether it's in Venezuela
where you don't can't have a gun or any
place where the you know Society or the
uh civilization or the people don't have
a weapon to defend themselves you're
going to be at the whim of tyrannical
governments and Bullies so to answer
your question I think it helped weaker
people defend themselves all right but I
want to I want to push back slightly no
no I'm way smarter than you and I
here's I I believe your argument is
correct as far as it goes and the
question is is it correct in the end
right you can take that same argument
and you could apply it to nuclear
weapons and you could say actually what
we want to do is have every country be
armed with nuclear weapons because then
big countries won't bully small
countries
if you did that
the nuclear war that we will ultimately
face will be that much sooner right
because you have that many itchy trigger
fingers that could initiate the thing
and so I'm not convinced that even I
mean look we saw
that nuclear weapons did
um produce peace it worked but in the
end is that their net effect we can't
measure that because we're not at the
end so I don't know within that effect
of Guns is I do believe the effect
you're describing is real and important
the only caveat that I would say I can't
believe I'm pushing back on you right
now is that the the capacity for these
nuclear weapons
in the wrong hands could literally end
Earth as we know it whereas a gun or an
M16 yes there could be some Carnage but
you're not literally blowing up the
world so nuclear weapons to a certain
extent is you know that threshold where
it's like don't cross that line Brad you
can't let a Playboy argue with you this
guy's resume it's just it's not you
you're a former professor of
evolutionary biology he's a he's a form
of an evolutionary biology there is
biology there but it's difficult
it's a different time let's go through
that let's go through that so okay so
guns specific guns not nuclear guns
benefited you know the average person's
like listen that guy's been bullying the
city this time he comes around hey you
can't do this anymore you got to get out
of my house okay [__] I'm not messing
with that family I'm out because they
got a gun fantastic right it's like when
you got the sign in a backyard beware
there's a uh German Shepherd and beware
there's no dog but that sign itself gets
some people to say I don't want to mess
with that place and there's a study
showing that there's a percentage of
people that don't mess with a house that
just has that sign whether there is a
real dog or not it still helps you to
create some safety nuclear fine internet
you know a lot of people were worried
about internet at the beginning you have
radio you have TV you have all this
stuff right who did who did YouTube
scare who did the anchor or you know
Spotify uh benefit and hurt if you if we
think about who YouTube and Spotify and
these places hurt it hurt mainstream
media it scared the crap out of the
bullies that have been telling everybody
one side of the story now you got to sit
there and listen to the number one
podcast in the world Joe Rogan telling
you a different way because he's got a
guess that got you thinking now we're
going out there doing research going to
Google which at one point we were
concerned so does chat gbt chat GPT
scare intellectuals is it where
intellectuals are sitting there saying
and professors are sitting there saying
uh oh if if this happens like in the
insurance industry I'm in the live
fictional space the moment they started
doing Predictive Analytics without
needing Underwriters and saying Brett
you don't need to do blood and urine
anymore we don't need to do that anymore
we don't need Underwriters anymore
here's the test we're going to be taking
on you we're going to get your social
media score we're going to get this
we're going to get this we're going to
get this based on that your preferred
Elite underwriting you're healthy you're
going to live till 85 mom lived to 89
dad lived to this you're going to be
fine right we don't need Underwriters
Underwriters sat down they're like dude
don't you can't stop this I I'm a
quarter million a year there's no way I
want you to get rid of my job this is
scary right but guess what that's
Innovation getting rid of Underwriters
could this model get rid of some
educational system that will replace
professors and they're sitting there
worried saying hey I've been bragging
about how smart I am now I can't do that
anymore this is not cool
yes and you know there's
we have just watched the entire
expert class
um fail a real world test
right we watched all the universities
every science department they have all
just failed a major test so and you know
if you were inside that system and you
kept your wits about you you knew that
there was a problem with competence you
knew that a lot of that was fakery and
nonsense right it sounds it looks like
science but it doesn't function like
science if you actually understand the
magic that makes science work you knew
it wasn't taking place in these
departments that it wasn't taking place
in the major journals and so on the one
hand
it is possible that something like chat
GPT helps us discover
the level of incompetence that is
putting us in Jeopardy which would be
great but my concern is that it actually
arms the next wave of incompetence so
that it sounds competent and so it's
harder to detect and
my guess is that ladder problem
outweighs the benefit of the former well
I mean we you took me to a whole
different place we've already been
having that I mean we have a president
that is uh giving speeches of people
that gave the speech 10 or 20 years
prior to him and sounding very
presidential and getting caught
plagiarizing John F Kennedy's speech or
Ted Kennedy's speech or all these other
people's speech so plagiarism's not
going away people sound very very
intellectual I think what what is going
to be interesting is we can right now
produce a robot if we don't already have
it that would be the UFC champion for
every weight okay we can probably
produce a robot I don't know if you've
seen that one robot that shoots three
pointers and how accurate it is have you
seen that one or no Steph Curry a robot
no no it's not even Steph Curry it's
better than Steph is 43 42 percent this
guy is like just hitting him left and
right okay perfect accuracy and he's
shooting the ball so the robot James the
robot Jordan yeah it's but uh uh so you
know we're already going in that
direction but do you really want to see
robots playing no you know if we can
create a robot to go into UFC and fight
them am I really intimidated by that
probably not now the future of robots
that are military that's a different
story that's concerning but you know
intellectuals debating like if you were
to have a debate with Chad gbt you're
probably going to lose the debate not in
the sense of who's right or who's wrong
who can recite more information and
remember and memorize well the the
ability to memorize as an individual
it was very a valuable skill set 20
years ago today you know you can just go
somewhere do it but I think we're still
going to want to see hand-to-end combat
with people debating and going out of
versus just debating a machine right and
the question is will you be able to know
what you're seeing so uh I I used to
tell students interesting that you are
here in this classroom to enhance the
capacity of your mind you are not here
to learn things right things are now
freely available on the internet you
don't need to go to school to access
them what you need to do here is
practice how well your mind functions
and so yeah you know today
I would I would beat the pants off chat
GPT
because I wouldn't let it come down to
volumes of information on a volumes of
information question then you know if
chat gpt3 can't do it gpt4 will but at
the level of the ability to
um reason and I'm not arguing that
there's no ability because we've
actually seen it right the fact that
this thing can write code and fixed code
is incredible and that is a kind of
thinking even if it's not doing it in a
way that we recognize as as a valid
cognition
but
um
but we do have to worry about what the
future is going to look like and you
know I already don't think that we know
exactly what we see when somebody's
giving you know especially somebody very
powerful is giving a speech on
television
um but we uh we're going to be in a
world of confusion once you
um plug this thing into our mechanisms
for sense making yeah it's going to be
all I know is it's going to be
interesting to see what happens next
this thing is not going to be slowing
down by the way it keeps getting smarter
and smarter let's talk about covet okay
we had Neil deGrasse Tyson here did you
watch the clip where it was specifically
to covet clip him and I uh talking about
it and he was given his point of view
when you hurt him okay I'm sure you were
saying to yourself Patrick say this you
know he needs to know this and what
about this and what about that what was
your take when you heard uh Neil
deGrasse Tyson uh give his views on the
vaccine
um I I had a number of responses
first let's give him his due though
he was way out of his depth but the
point his underlying point isn't
incorrect is just not applicable
so his underlying point was that there
is a game theoretic problem that
surrounds issues of Public Health
and that we are in a position to do
ourselves great harm if we don't
recognize that issue and address it and
to give you a
a trivial example that everyone will
agree on
the fact is that washing your hands
after you use the toilet is not about
protecting yourself it's about
protecting other people and we formally
and informally enforce a rule where
people have to wash their hands because
the benefit to all of us of having
people who prepare our food for example
wash their hands or anybody who's going
to touch a doorknob
is so great compared to the cost that we
each pay for washing our own hands that
it's a it's a slam dunk winner right so
that kind of game theory exists
potentially in the space of things like
vaccination
and I will just I'll describe it this
way
if you had a good vaccine one that
really provided sterilizing immunity to
a serious disease then and it had some
risk right there's a there's a what we
call a free rider problem which is if
you imagine that you start vaccinating
people for this disease and that the
benefit comes from having more and more
people vaccinated so the disease can't
find vulnerable individuals to use as
vectors
then the closer you get to vaccinating
everybody the less value there is in
vaccinating the next person because
you've already got a population that has
hurt immunity so if you want to not
experience not face your share of the
risk of that program then you don't get
vaccinated and everybody else is taking
the risk on your behalf gives you the
benefit too so the Free Rider comes out
ahead because they get the benefit of
the vaccination program and they don't
pay the cost of it right that's a real
problem in the context
of a an actually good vaccine that
carries some risk with it and what it
will do is it may drive the number the
fraction of the population that gets the
vaccine down to a point where we don't
have herd immunity and the disease
continues to circulate right so that's
the problem that he wants to solve
the the issue comes that we have a
completely polluted set of information
available to the public about the nature
of the so-called vaccines that were
deployed for covid about the
effectiveness of those vaccines that's
those so-called vaccines at preventing
disease serious or otherwise and the
safety of those inoculations
so what you heard in your exchange with
him
was a guy who effectively believed the
public health apparatus in what it told
him and couldn't imagine how anybody
would reach a different conclusion now
many of us including me did reach a
different conclusion and you know for
all of us it started somewhere
for for Heather and me it started when
we were hearing about these so-called
vaccines for the first time
and we were told like everybody else
that these things were highly effective
against kovid and safe
and when we heard the claim that they
were safe we knew something was wrong
because there is no conceivable way
there is literally no way they could be
safe right they could have been harmless
they didn't turn out to be harmless but
they could have been harmless but safe
implies that you know at the point that
claim is made that they are harmless
that they don't have any long-term
impacts that are worth knowing about
and they hadn't been around long enough
there was no prior example of such a
inoculation used in another creature
that would have allowed us to determine
that so if these people were telling the
truth what they would have said was well
I don't want to say because I think we
now know that this wasn't the truth even
then but if they had said we don't know
of any harms and we don't believe they
are likely but we cannot promise you
they don't exist right then it would
have been a very different story but at
the point they said oh these things are
safe the point is Ah that's a lie I
don't know why it's a lie I don't know
if they're solving a game theory problem
and they actually believe that or
they're solving a business problem and
I'm the Mark I don't know but I do know
something's wrong with the claim and at
the point that we realized something was
wrong with that claim we started to dig
the further we dug the worse it got and
you know that sort of led us to a second
line of inquiry which was well what is
the likelihood that a
inoculation based on this technology
would be safe and the answer was
very very low
and the reason I say that is because the
technology in question especially the
MRNA
uh inoculation or transfectant
was so radically different from anything
that had been successfully deployed
before that the chances it was going to
have some impact on the immune system on
the circulatory system on neurological
systems the likelihood that there was
going to be something in there that it
disrupted was extremely high because
complex systems are that way there are
so many interrelated parts that there's
no way to predict what the impacts will
be and the likelihood of improving a
functional organism with such a thing is
low
so I have two questions for you sure one
did you watch uh uh the Pfizer CEO at uh
Davos being chased down and asked and
all the questions and they didn't have a
response from did you see that by the
way that clip is not on YouTube so we're
not going to be playing it it can be on
Twitter you can go find it we'll put a
link for it if people want to see it
but it's a very interesting uh uh back
and forth for two or three minutes and
the guy walked for a long time the
question I got for you is the part and
this is where a lot of people message me
the interview got nearly a hundred
thousand comments is what it got not in
the span of six years in the span of two
weeks you got 100 000 comments first six
hours it already had forty thousand
comments Neil deGrasse yeah there's a
part where he says there's a public
health contract
that you have signed implicitly as a
citizen of a country where in part we
depend on each other for health our
wealth our security and the like and
that contract is in the best scientific
evidence available at the time if you do
not get vaccinated you will put other
people in this organization at risk and
that organization does not want to take
that risk so you do not have this job
anymore if you decline it so in in with
any public health decision there has to
be a consequence to you not
participating in this social contract
Which social contract is he talking
about public health contract is he
talking about well this is exactly what
I was getting at when I I said we should
give him his due in principle he's not
wrong the problem is that the person or
the entity into which you have entered
this contract without your choice by the
way but
which you have been forced to enter this
contract is in breach of that exact
contract right that is why this is a
non-question that is why there is
exactly no right to mandate these things
is because in order
to have any legitimacy to such a policy
you would have to take every precaution
to protect the public from the perverse
incentives inside of science inside of
Pharma inside of Public Health and no
precautions were taken in fact what
appears to have happened is the complete
capture of the system that should be
protecting us so
in the case
that you had a truly dangerous disease
you had let's say that we had a a true
vaccine something based on a reliable
technology something like an attenuated
virus-based vaccine in which proper
testing had been done by an independent
Authority which had evaluated the level
of Adverse Events to be low had looked
at past examples of similar vaccines and
said the likelihood that there is
something hiding here that we don't know
is low here are the all-cause mortality
statistics on previous vaccines that
have been out for many decades
right then there would have been at
least the basis for a discussion about a
mandate but we are so far from having a
structure that is capable of managing
that responsibility that it is
inconceivable that those mandates would
have been Justified and of course
the fact that they did not instantly get
removed at the point we discovered these
things did not block transmission of the
disease tells you this wasn't about
public health in the first place this
was about something else I don't know
that we know what that something else
was but it wasn't good it wasn't about
us in the public it was about something
perhaps it was business that's the best
case scenarios that this was agreed
driving this but it certainly wasn't
keeping people safe money
uh that's the floor the explanation
could be worse but at least this was
runaway greed and a complete
indifference to the suffering and death
of other people's children
can I just ask a simple question this is
not my wheelhouse um this is I I would
like the audience to maybe get some some
very specific clear answers uh every
country had a sort of a different
approach every state America had a
different approach we saw what happened
in California lockdowns New York versus
Florida DeSantis all that if you could
uh give a grade to America's response as
a country and then what countries out
there would you give an a to in the
response to everything that happened in
2020.
I don't think an a was possible there
you know if you know if we're grading on
a curve you know Sweden did yeah the old
educational system yeah well he wants to
know whether he got an A or B right
planet Earth got an F minus on this one
okay and you know planet Earth got an F
minus
that's not even harsh enough
like let's just be clear about this no
matter what ended up being true about
these so-called vaccines about early
treatment about the proliferation of
variants that comes from the vaccination
campaign no matter what we conclude on
all of those topics at the very least
we have a virus that appears to have
been the product of a
circumvention of a law that was
created by Congress to protect us from
gain of function research that resulted
in Anthony fauci using a proxy to
Offshore that work to the lab in Wuhan
China where they appear to have enhanced
this virus's capacity to infect human
beings
every single bad thing that happened to
us including the trillions of dollars of
wealth that got evaporated all of the
people who have been killed by the virus
or some consequence of lockdowns or some
consequence of these inoculants right
all of those costs come from that error
so
you know this is a self-inflicted wound
from one end to the other this is the
greatest blunder in human history and
for the same people
who are responsible for that blunder to
have been put in charge of protecting us
when they clearly had perverse
incentives was insane any country to get
an A on this exam would have had to call
that out and say actually
this can't be managed by the same people
who created it we need to find the best
Minds the most independent minds and we
need to start with a fresh sheet of
paper that doesn't involve those people
and figure out what the right thing to
do is and if we had done that even after
the virus had gotten loose and spread
around the globe we would have done
vastly better would there have been
deaths yes many but we would have done
vastly better so the fact that at best
provinces ignored the Global Response
and did their own thing and saved their
own populations right uttar Pradesh used
Ivermectin right do we know what the
consequence of that was not exactly
but we don't know because there is a
an obsession with not finding out much
as there is an obsession with not
finding out what Adverse Events are
actually happening at what rate right
from the MRNA vaccines so we simply have
to escape the people who have control
over what questions we are allowed to
ask what we are allowed to study and we
need to figure out what happens so that
this can never happen again so so let me
let me ask you this question this is my
Challenge and this is kind of where I
was going with it uh what things are the
left
certain about and what things are the
right certain about what things are
liberals certain about what things are
conservative certain about
that they're not correct no no either
way look listen here's the Republicans
are wrong the Democrats are wrong on
this 100 they're wrong on this or we the
Democrats are right on this we the
Republicans are right on this what
things
on both sides are they certain they're
right or wrong
do you know what I'm asking not exactly
so for example I'll give you an idea
uh
uh we make the right the right thing to
do is to get the vaccine or else you
know the the World's Gonna Die the right
thing to do with climate change we have
to make that a priority because in 12
years we may cease to exist you know the
right thing to do is we are 100 right
climate change is real you know what
things would you say the the left is
100 certain they're right and the other
side is wrong and then vice versa well I
mean
I think this is just a different a
different puzzle than the one you're
asking about we have
teams right we have a blue team and a
red team these things amount to jerseys
and the fact is you have good soldiers
on both sides right who wear the jersey
and believe all of the stuff that the
other people who wear that same Jersey
and go to the same parties believe and
so it's just like a a really insane
slate of things that have been
incoherently uh put together right and
it's really the Hallmark of low quality
thinking that people sign up for the
Full Slate right it would be normal if
you you know the people that you were
aligned with politically had a set of
beliefs and you thought well I'm with
them on this this and this I'm halfway
there on this one and I disagree with
them on these two right that would be
normal but the idea that oh yeah you
know the New York Times that it speaks
for me wow you got to be some amazing
level of confused if you think I got a
story for you I'm going to show here in
a minute not right now but keep going
well it has it's to give credit to New
York Times maybe if it's not credit but
you'll see her in a minute I look
forward to hearing about that it's been
some time since the New York Times
deserved any credit but you'll see what
it is here in a second um but anyway so
you know we could go through those
um you know slates of disagreements on
both sides and the problem is that all
of these things require adult level
Nuance that isn't found in either of
these you know simple sets of
prescriptions
so let me maybe set up why I'm asking
the question okay for me I come from the
school of thought of man we don't know
it's a test
we're testing and we could be wrong
meaning
Sweden took a test took a risk hey work
out for them the scientists took a risk
could have worked out against him sure
worked against him but it worked on his
benefit
Cuomo took a risk got him fired maybe
for other reasons but he got fired
Newsome took a risk not a good look for
California you know Illinois took a risk
Texas took a risk South Dakota took a
risk a lot of people took a risk every
leader took a risk the the risk to me
that uh uh was annoying was when people
were 100 right that they are 100 right
rather than saying look this is the
strategy we're using to beat the enemy
none of us know 100 whether we're going
to be right or wrong nobody knows 100
but this is the choices that we have
our encouragement is if you're afraid
you have an option go take the vaccine
but you know we feel confident about the
amount of research that we've gotten so
far obviously if we had five or ten
years we would be more certain because
we've we've done more testing
but if you're still comfortable taking
it in a military they came up to us
remember back in the days Anthrax shot
so they came in the Army this is how it
was for the Army by the way just so you
know now it's starting to make sense
because I'm going back and realizing
when my you know kind of like
they came in they said uh you guys are
taking an Anthrax shot I'm like what are
you talking about well your government
property
and so the sergeants are talking to us
Sergeant Braxton are these guys telling
the truth you signed that contract man
in that situation you did sign a
contract you are government property you
are theirs for eight years right so
guess what shot we have to take we have
to take the shot now we would say so how
much do we know about what's going on
not you know typically first line of
defense first testing goes through
military and you're part of it right do
you know how many people took it we're
like do this am I gonna grow you know
fourth arm am I going to be a two-headed
Assyrian you know what's what's gonna
happen here right but people were scared
and a lot of debate what's going on but
they told you
this could cause a lot of side effects
you have to sign this waiver that the
military can never be held liable for
XYZ and we had already signed it anyway
so we didn't have a choice but at least
it's to say this comes with side effects
you take the medication what does the
medication say you know they made uh
Philip Morris put what on the cigarettes
this could cause cancer bro if you want
to smoke it smoke but you could die from
cancer guess what I'm okay with that
because you're telling me what my risks
are my concern was they were too
confident that their weight was 100 the
right way in the opposition had no
opportunity question them that was my
biggest chance so when I'm asking a
question about you know which side
thinks they're more certain in different
areas the left was very very certain
their way was the right way or you know
hit the road if you can take a different
approach well uh
two responses one I noticed as my kids
were growing up that I would ask them
what they thought was going on in some
case and they would tell me and I would
say how certain are you and they would
say 100 and I would say it wrong
and so anyway I started to force them to
put a number on the likelihood that they
were oh I would get along and it could
be a very tiny number right but the
point is you need to have what right it
can be a fraction of one percent but it
can't be zero right and I would also say
that in the context of covid and and
most significantly the vaccination
campaign
there was a nightmare scenario for
Heather and me
and unfortunately we had to root for it
right this was torture
because on the one hand we were
confident
that we could not be confident of the
safety of these things nobody could
there was no way you could have
certainty about their safety because
they had not been around long enough to
know what their consequence would be a
year down the road or two years down
there and that's a reasonable level of
skepticism it was should have been
uncontroversial but the problem is what
could have happened is we could have
said hey whoa wait a minute these things
can't be safe that has to be a lie
because nobody knows what happens three
years down the road
and there could have been no
consequences which would have been the
best outcome by far right
and it would have ruined our credibility
because most people don't understand
that to say that is not safe is
different than saying that does harm
right so we left the door open
to any possibility and just said look
the the only thing to be certain of is
that we can't be certain of something
like safety in this case and so we had
to root for our own
destruction
we had to root that the vaccines would
be harmless
and it was a very uncomfortable spot to
be in because you know on the one hand
you want them to be harmless of course
and on the other hand I don't know what
we do for a living after that
right so
um that's the predicament of adult level
Nuance right it's not a safe business
and
um
how confident are you that now that
McCarthy and you know some of the guys
pushed uh they went 15 rounds until he
finally was announced you know speaker
of the house because there was a lot of
deals being made where they're going to
go investigate fauci and you know all of
the vaccine stuff how confident are you
that Rand Paul and his camp they're
gonna get to the bottom of this and
we're going to find that exactly how
this thing got out how much you know
like just the same thing that we learned
about Twitter files are we going to
learn new things about it controversy
about it
are we eventually going to get to the
truth uh I doubt it really I don't I
think we will get to more truth than
we've got but the system has a way of
protecting itself and what it's going to
do is reveal no more than it has to and
so from our perspective in the public if
we don't want this to happen to us again
we have to push so that the amount that
it has to cough up is a greater fraction
of the whole but no I I uh I strongly
doubt we will fully get to the bottom of
what happened here quick point about
this this 100 level of certainty in
general like we've all been around those
people it's like how confident you are
you 100 bro I'm telling you it's 100
percent
you know how like in polling we've seen
the pollsters get it wrong for decades
now why can't they implement this margin
of error use usually what three percent
give or take why can't we I got too many
take that and put that into people's
opinions or even something as as
essential as covet or anything like this
it's like all right you can no longer
say a quick question sick question we
got two minutes so this is what I want
to do before going there can you pull up
we have to give a shout out to New York
Times our sponsors uh especially after
this article you read I'm sure you guys
going to be buying their magazine uh I'm
I'm convinced you're going to be
subscribing to them and reading every
article of theirs when I read this I'm
like what like the level of stuff they
write I mean you think this is a joke
okay here's New York Times there has
never been a better time to be short
okay so this article goes down keep
going down and it says how it is bad you
know something from where I stand at
five feet seven being tall is widely
held fantasy Superior in Arizona it made
sense of fawn over height when facility
ages ago when necessary is defending
yourself if you go all the way to the
bottom and read this article you know
what it's really saying how tall people
should stop having kids okay how sure
it's shorter people are better for
society why we should go back to being
short and not being taller why it's not
fair I mean
the average person who has logic who
reads this says
who even approved this opinion to be
written with the Brand New York Times
unless if you're just trying to get a
lot of eyeballs for people to talk about
it okay what do you see with the level
of credibility New York Times has today
I know you're a big fan of this I know
you're like a big spokesperson for them
going around always trying to get people
to subscribe I mean I I'm just I'm
endlessly shocked and disappointed by
the New York Times and you know the
Washington Post too and really all of
the mainstream media but the question is
why is this you know project Mockingbird
just simply one or is this the breakdown
incompetence having produced a newspaper
that you know wouldn't know news if it
hit it in the face or would you secretly
fantasize about owning them
the New York Times I I never fantasize
about owning the New York Times no you
wouldn't want to be like the
editor-in-chief or I think they've done
too much damage to the brand for it to
be anything other than funny
but what's your level of certainty
though 100 97 where are you at on this
uh that it would be good to on the New
York Times I'm at three percent yeah
you go I like it okay by the way I wish
we had more time truly enjoyed it I just
looked at I'm like oh shoot I need
another two hours with this guy I really
enjoyed being I'm looking forward to
bringing you back and hopefully next
time Rob next time we do a let's do it
at a time that's not on a Dream Team
call so we can go more than two hours
because two hours with Brett is not
enough time it was just getting started
but uh uh for folks who enjoy today's
podcast and you'd like to find more
information on bread Brett has a podcast
called The Dark Horse if I'm saying it
correctly Dark Horse podcast Dark Horse
podcast you can find it all over the
place what's the main place you'd like
us to push it to if you were to go to
one spot Spotify Spotify let's put the
Spotify link to the podcast so people
can go uh find it Brett appreciate you
for coming out this was great cannot
wait to do it again thanks me too take
care everybody bye bye bye